it has a very deep vibe and maybe an
emotional vibe
oh is this the one in the mirror this is
why I love your accent hi my name is
Carlos dear Donny if you had the
opportunity to date someone from another
country which country would be from I'd
have to go with London more so because
I'm a big Harry Potter fan so if she has
a cool British accent that would be kind
of nice how are you feeling right now
fine I'm fine I'm fine here we go hi
ladies how we doing first just it looks
like natural the second ones like I'm
here look at me right I got my ways and
keys out and I was a square for a good
two week is it oh my wait so this isn't
like a snapchat filter or anything no
that that's my actual face okay you got
a motorcycle or some sort I do I do
with the motorbike you know wow I need
some backstory on this picture it's yeah
it's a mini toaster Game of Thrones I
love Game of Thrones although I'm upset
at the last season because really the
writers good my brother
oh my god the one we're here upside down
joke's on you I'm not I love the baby
pic that's smart so you want to get into
the funny side when you were yeah monkey
do you see it I'm peeing on me oh my god
I do see it being on it's like it's got
the leg up and you like rock and roll
yeah I do like rock music any any time
any day what I'm showering I'm just like
you work with kids that's really cool
actually I work with the Boys and Girls
Club - Wow
I love your style you have a great style
feel like if we go on a date I just have
to show you off that would be great
Rifle Association so you could shoot oh
yeah I ask you it has a very deep vibe
and maybe an emotional vibe oh is this
the one in the mirror this is allowing
both grads a cup of coffee
yeah I actually don't drink any coffee
what how do you survive she's like she's
like in the ocean just looking back like
what's good or you have a very nice
clean face how are you not too great
struggling yeah I get it
Carlos you have to eliminate five girls
make a decision now hi everyone first of
all you guys were all really nice to
talk to if I had the chance to meet all
of y'all I would but I'm going to have
to eliminate first off millennia I'm so
sorry I just don't feel like you would
click oh sorry Tanisha meet you guys and
you call us well the next person that
I'll be eliminating is Siobhan you why
are you breaking up with me
[Music]
finally I loved I loved above your pizza
oven cake but I'm sorry Briana
[Music]
love you girls
it was definitely not my type but it was
really nice I thought my pizza oven
picture was gold every single one of
those girls was so so lovely was I
expecting that yes I'm from Costa Rica
so hello latina/o castle and I'm from
Chile I'm Switzerland I'm from Canada
thank you for Canada so I'm Jennings
enough of France I'm originally I'm from
Vietnam
but we must earn our way like eight
years ago I've just been living here I'm
from Rio Brazil from Canada well I am
from Malaysia all the way across the sea
I will actually don't know where you are
so I'm in Los Angeles area that's nice I
just visited last year made the trip for
comic-con DC or marvel also you said
something about coffee I also don't
drink coffee and I'm like my mom or
England I live in Barcelona my year
abroad how is your Spanish concept
espanol oh my name is faith I'm from
Brazil I'm in a country called Oman it's
close to like two by MBM in Saudi Arabia
are you in uni are you uni was that mean
University oh excuse me yes I am a
recent college graduate I am from
Singapore I'm from Mississippi hey
coffee I like literally every day I wake
up and I'm like this I love life I love
positivity l enjoy I love just
everything
[Music]
have to eliminate and lure first I just
really didn't connect as well really
does the second person I will have to
eliminate is Angie Roxanne sounds good I
just think that other girls gave me more
energetic answers so I'm gonna have to
eliminate lil I'm so sorry I was also
really awkward because I didn't hear
when he said my name AHA what did you
say
so it was kind of surreal to speak to
certain people from all these different
places I was so interesting I've already
added like all of them on Instagram
round three is gonna be the kitchen tour
I feel like we should do this like MTV
Cribs style have you watched MTV Cribs
okay so I'm gonna do a little like P
Diddy tight welcome to my crib we got
two fridges non saying why are your
bananas moldy we did you say that's not
a banana no it's fun mean it's bigger
than a banana so this is the reader is
this some people are doing this is there
anything you'd recommend that I learned
how to cook I would go for a classic
feijoada which is like the Brazilian
beans which are the best in the world
I'm sorry to say but they are peanut
butter then we've got the most Canadian
thing you can find in a fridge you put
it on everything like yeah like an L I
put it on my spaghetti good reference
that's a great movie I really want to
eat sushi I've never had this pleasure
in my life I love sushi let's go eat
some sometime I can go and watch you eat
it I thought you said you were gonna
like try to I'm allergic to most of the
think applesauce applesauce I don't know
what that it is actually
oh my god wow those little yellow cups
yeah it's like Apple but like crushed
that's can put in French I don't know
how to say it okay this is rice because
I'm Asian and we got to have our rice
I'm a huge flaming hot cheetos girl but
we don't have so much Cheetos in
Malaysia like next best thing it's
called twisties the first person I'm
gonna eliminate is theis I'm so sorry
the lack of sushi I feel like we
wouldn't be able to enjoy some seafood
itself I hope I can meet sushi one day
the next girl I will eliminate
I feel like we just didn't get along
then click as well I'm gonna eliminate
Jessica
see at this point I've narrowed it down
to everyone that I think has a great
personality now I think it's just gonna
be attraction based to a more attractive
but you guys are all beautiful all of
you so oh I'm gonna have to go with
Jennings and Sosa I got to go with
Natalie on this one I love your vibe but
I'd want to be your friend girls nice to
meet you our final elimination through
this round one more I thought that was
it oh I'm gonna go with Val on this one
I honestly did not think it was gonna
get past the first round snow was
already a pleasant surprise I wish he
felt he finds a very cute girl because
everyone there was gorgeous I really
wish the best for Carlos and I really
hope that we're gonna be friends when I
go back to LA so so let's say I go to
Canada right and we meet up what would
be your ideal date to take us on I think
we would go on a hike to like a hidden
little place we could go cliff jump
because I love that I'm sorry I'm sorry
little red or white wine white because
I'm basic I'm so sorry I have no
self-control maybe a really nice
breakfast that back you lies you which
is the National Park we could go to the
National Museum and just spend the whole
day looking at art which I would very
much enjoy giving like fancy school
sometimes but like I liked like simply
watch I would add projector so we can
watch a movie like a projector my like
back yard I like the wall of the house
make some homemade pizza
Julie corks I hate her like scary I
actually do like horror it's a good
person I will do it for them I'll suck
it up and watch me within I'll just
cover my eyes all the time
hey Gus definitely to downtown Toronto
that's definitely where it's at I feel
like the music scene and the art scene
there is pretty cool and I think you
said you're into idiom which I'm super
into Malaysia is huge fun food so we'll
go we'll get nasi lemak
which is our national dish we'll get
some chocolate ale which is like
stir-fried noodles
I love escape rooms you know it's a it's
a pretty heated situation and if we can
survive that
[Music]
the first person I will eliminate is and
this is only because the ideal date
didn't speak to me as much as the other
ones is Priscilla I'm sorry I'm just not
down for a museum date thank you so much
Carlos for being so respectful and kind
to all of the ladies that's very
important I'm gonna eliminate Julia or
for this one I'm so sorry so great thank
you so much okay see cuz all you guys
have like similar things that I like to
do but I think I like the height / mango
date a little bit more so I'm gonna
eliminate Julia excuse me sorry Lauren
excuse me I love you all you are all
amazing I've had a great experience
you've made it so much fun it's a good
experience it's a good day you gotta
push through this I know but I do you
guys this the whole experience is so
much fun thank you Jubilee for having me
fun fact I like girls too so if any
other girls involved if you like calling
me feel free as far as like your future
long-term goals like where do you see
yourself in ten years what do you want
to accomplish
I realize especially like oneexchange
how much I value in connection and like
relationship building and so I
definitely want to do something where
I'm able to combine those passions what
do you aspire to be in the future I am
actually currently in my dream job so
I'm a video producer and I basically do
very similar things to what we're doing
right now so probably take me somewhere
to Hollywood and that's right where you
are so I think that passion is the first
thing in starting a lifelong career for
me I found out okay what am i passionate
about and I found that helping the
community and serving is something I'd
like to do so I figured what can I do
with that and I thought law enforcement
being a police officer familywize you
want a family in the future anything
I mean eventually but not anytime soon I
have so much in the world to see still
like I have things I want to do I want
to go skydiving I want to do in the Air
Force so I hopefully I want to skydive
to fly me up there I know who I want
I've been leaning towards one person I
don't know what to say honestly you both
you ladies are amazing thank you so much
for taking the time to the day to or
night to to be here and to chat with me
this has been a wonderful experience but
Gwen I would like to go on a date with
you let's do such a great guy and we're
so lucky to have one she's welcome
hilarious I don't ask you this already
what time is it over there it is 3:30 in
the morning Gwen I'm gonna hit you up on
Instagram it's been a pleasure talking
to you I'm excited to see where this
goes good night good night yes please
get some sleep
do you ever think you're gonna get
matched up with someone from Malaysia
you're like I never that's what I'm
saying and I'm happy the the girls are
gonna have that afterparty honestly
that's gonna be fun you're gonna get
married
a big thank you to dash land for
supporting this episode for making our
content possible for those of you who
don't know - Lane is awesome it securely
generates and stores all of your
password information across every device
so you never have to click lost password
again it can start your passport info
your Wi-Fi info your banking info and
even auto fills or credit cards so you
never have to go searching through your
wallet which is super great for travel
yeah and speaking of trouble
there's also BPM so you won't be tracked
and you can access content while
browsing the Internet in other countries
so for all you good humans out there
make sure you go to - Lang comm slash
DubLi to get dashlane free on your first
device and make sure you use the code
Jubilee when you're ready to upgrade to
premium and get 10% off make sure to
LIKE comment subscribe and I'll see you
next time